OLIVIER DE WECK: One of
the key ways of learning
is to look at examples,
past examples,
of both successful and
failed projects or designs.
What we find in
systems engineering
is that often the problems
begin at the requirements stage,
where either a requirement is
missing, or there's redundancy,
or in some cases
requirements are
written that are
overly ambitious
and utopian given the time
frame and the budget available.
So what you have is always a
trade off between how ambitious
you are technically,
the schedule,
and the budget that's
available, and how much
risk you are willing to take.
And so the students are
pushing the envelope
in these different dimensions
and learning what's feasible,
what's not feasible,
and what can we
learn from past failures.
We can learn from general
examples of projects
that had difficulties,
either in aerospace,
in the automotive industry,
in consumer products.
In hindsight, one
is always smarter.
But it is worth
to look at these.
Specifically with the
CanSat competition,
since the competition has a rich
history, and a very active set
of sponsors, and quite
a good website as well,
there's a lot of
opportunities to learn
from mistakes that other
teams have made in the past.
For example, designing a
glider where there's not
sufficient tolerances
between the vehicle itself
and the container, and basically
the deployment doesn't go well.
Another example is
designing a glider
that does not fly properly
in a circular pattern,
and flies too well actually, and
flies off into the woods never
to be seen again.
There's, of course, a
lot of lessons learned
from establishing a stable
communications link,
from having worked
out procedures.
How do you deploy your system?
How do you test it?
How do you communicate with it?
How do you collect it?
How do you
post-process the data?
In each of those
critical areas, we
see that learning
from the past is
critical to avoid
mistakes that could be
avoided with these learnings.